Oh  you  you  thank you in this game beautiful life  it's gonna take you for a ride  it does  only to trust visually my daddy knew I  would like the rest of him  and what he loved the most about me was  that I was exactly like him go make us  their money  [Music]  you're crazy just like yo yeah I know my  [ __ ] is bad but if you keep standing  I'm like that I'm not to charge show me  any gonna do it baby  sorry I'm looking at me  did you like yeah I got game huh I got  some new girls working for me  only going up for me from you me  you can never leave me  she's not a work Bowman or you can die  this is your future right here you and  me remember and I may not have been a  best mother in the world with sometimes  you get to live the life you want to  live  [Music]  they gonna search every street  like my said times you don't get to  choose like you won't gives you weight  away have girl here pill  oh girl all pimp  [Music]  you  you